IT'S TIME TO PLAY "WITCH,
PLEASE!"
HALLOWEEN IS THE BEST TIME OF
YEAR TO CELEBRATE YOUR FAVORITE
POP CULTURE CHARACTERS, OR JUST
DRESS LIKE AN ASSHOLE AND FILL A
PLASTIC PUMPKIN WITH PUKE.
THE FOLLOWING COSTUMES ARE MORE
FOR THE LATTER.
COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU
A TERRIBLE HALLOWEEN GET-UP AND
FOR 250 POINTS, I WANT YOU TO
GIVE ME A TAGLINE TO
HELP SELL IT.
FIRST UP, THE BIG BABY!
GODDAMN IT!
THAT IS WORSE THAN THE HASHTAG
WE PLAYED.
DOUG BENSON.
>> IT'S NOT YOUR PARTY, BUT YOU
CAN CRY IF YOU WANT TO, YOU
STUPID BABY. YOU BIG, STUPID
BABY.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
ESTHER.
>> THIS ONE WILL DEFINITELY RUIN
MY VAGINA.
LAUGH.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
POINTS.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU NEED THIS
HALLOWEEN?
YOU NEED SEXY DONALD TRUMP!
>> Chris: DOUG.
>> LET'S MAKE AMERICA'S
HALLOWEEN PARTIES GREAT AGAIN.
>> Chris: YEAH, POINTS.
BY THE WAY, GUYS, IT'S OKAY TO
NOT TRY TO MAKE EVERYTHING
(BLEEP)ABLE. IT'S OKAY.
>> I'M GOING TO BE SEXY STEVE
JOBS FOR HALLOWEEN.
>> Chris: IS THAT TRUE?
>> YEAH.
>> Chris: THAT'S AWESOME. I HAVE
TO GIVE YOU 100 POINTS FOR THAT,
JUST FOR THAT FACT ALONE.
ESTHER.
>> THIS MODEL WOULD MAKE A
BETTER PRESIDENT.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS, POINTS.
( APPLAUSE )
>> CHECK OUT HER T-RUMP.
>> Chris: WELL PLAYED.
>> Chris: NEXT UP BARRY
BONDAGE.
BARRY BONDAGE.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT I WAS EXPECTING, BUT IT
WASN'T THAT.
TONY.
>> LOOK LIKE A GIANT TESTICLE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
DOUG.
>> FIRST OF ALL, IS THAT-- IS
THAT A PADDLE OR A BIG ICE CREAM
BAR?
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE ).
>> Chris: MAYBE A LITTLE FROM
COLUMN "A" AND A LITTLE FROM
COLUMN "B."
BY THE WAY, GUYS, SOLD
OUT.
FIVE STARS.
ESTHER.
>> JUST, YOU KNOW, THIS IS THE
ONLY THING THAT WILL LITERALLY
TURN EVERYONE IN THE WORLD OFF.
>> Chris: YEAH, POINTS.
>> IT KIND OF LOOKS LIKE-- IT--
IT COULD BE A SEXY PIKACHU
FROM THE NECK DOWN.
>> I GET THE FEELING THIS IS THE
LAST THING LAMAR ODOM SAW
BEFORE HE BLACKED OUT.
>> Chris: WELL, I DON'T-- YOU
KNOW, WE WEREN'T THERE.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
NEXT FOR THE LITTLE ONES, THIS
BABY D.J. COSTUME.
DOUG.
>> LOOK, IT'S D.J. POOPY PANTS
ON THE 1s AND 2s.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, POINTS.
POINTS.
TONY.
>> GIVE YOUR KIDS S.I.D.S.--
SUDDEN INFANT DANCE SYNDROME.
>> Chris: THAT'S A GREAT JOKE.
POINTS. ESTHER.
>> JUST AS WORTHLESS AS A REAL
D.J.
>> Chris: THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING, THE HUMAN BLOW-UP DOLL.
THE HUMAN BLOW-UP DOLL.
TONY.
>> NOW WITH REAL-SIZED DOUG
BENSON DICK.
>> Chris: OOOH!
WHY?
WHY TAKE A SHOT AT POOR DOUG?
>> I WISH.
WAIT, WHAT?
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
ESTHER.
>> DRESS UP AS DOUG BENSON'S
GIRLFRIEND.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
EVERYONE'S-- EVERYONE'S
ASSAULTING DOUG BENSON.
>> FINALLY I GOT A ROAST ON
COMEDY CENTRAL!
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )